hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm your co-host
Geo and I'm Bart you know how I'm like
uh let me know how this problem because
you're literally with one of the sexiest
guys on the planet
uh you're talking about yourself yes
what makes you sexy
okay the drive are you ready are you
ready because I I'm so glad you asked
that question God damn it are you ready
I guess so if you are a connoisseur of
fine quality Goods okay do this as slow
as possible
literally like scan from here
and go all the way down and the slower
you go the more pleasure you'll
experience so go ahead
it looks like you have a vagina
okay now what now what happens and then
that feeling that's inside yeah I almost
threw up a little bit no trust me did it
how wait why am I going to trust you
about what I my body just did because
I'm a doctor
fine what were you gonna say why are you
sexy I'm just sexy because I'm I'm a
sexy but anyways uh what I wanted to ask
you is uh obviously I'm a very weird
person right I'm like really quirky I
got dry fee I got flat feet I got really
bad Vision I needed braces
um that doesn't make you weird yeah
eczema on my balls
um I have like ADHD like I'm all [ __ ]
up but somehow you literally just
described how you're not sexy and prove
my point yes awesome so I'm the most
unsexiest man alive hell yeah oh yeah
okay wait a minute and somehow uh you're
able to find it in your heart to oh
like give you a chance give you a try
not to let me like just in your mouth oh
my God so
um what I wanted to ask you oh no no so
I wanted to ask is like how did you
[ __ ] how did you just [ __ ] me over so
hard
how did you just [ __ ] me so so hard I
did it you [ __ ] did you [ __ ]
genius
how did you just [ __ ] me over how did I
[ __ ] you over I was trying to
kind of sexy okay then your unsexy ass
gave that to me yeah and then you
[ __ ] took it all away this false
[ __ ] Victory by going I have this
this this this this this this this this
this is how bad I suck and I'm like
and you still lick my balls and you
still lick my [ __ ] and I'm like oh
[ __ ] demolished maybe that's the
sexiest quality of me it's the
intangible
anyway
asking like why I what did I saw what I
saw on you no because I think like uh
uh you know I think quite a few people
think you're attractive
right I think so that's what they tell
me they tell you yeah and um who's
talking all this [ __ ] no they're saying
good things about you right they're
saying that and it always makes me feel
weird but yeah but you know and so I
wanted to ask you
um on a guy's end I'm not the
stereotypical sexy guy and even if they
saw you at the bar right like the sexy
elegant Geo and I'll admit you know I
concur with them and if they see you
like I guess I agree if they see a sexy
Geo at the bar and then they go pair her
with who you think looks right here at
this bar they're probably scan they'll
probably see me and pass right me to
right over me right and then go like oh
you know like they might look at like
some handsome dude over there some like
I don't know Ryan Gosling looking guy
over there really you think I should be
paired up with some guy Paul Walker look
and do it over there really uh Idris
Elba gut looking guy over there you know
like they might go like you know going
like that
and uh but obviously you're not with any
of them or anyone even close to them
yeah I've had ugly boyfriends yes I want
to know like what are some of the
nastiest qualities that you can overlook
everything because that's real wow
because that's interesting well I don't
know I take that back because that's not
true
um or what about this what's nasty to
the general public that you're like
maybe you don't care and what's nasty to
you that you actually do care
um okay so nasty to the general public I
think is well the U.S public like the
American public right or whatever public
you care about yeah so I only know
American [ __ ] right because if I were to
go to like China or something else it's
a different world that's the standard
right yeah because like in some
countries like K-pop is the epitome of
like masculinity not even that but like
let's say I go to like somewhere like
Japan right yeah
um and I don't know I sit I don't know
like I I'm just like really loud now I'm
like this obnoxious unattractive person
right yeah so that's all that's all I
mean oh I see um so
the uh what most people find
unattractive is like so we even have a
picture on Instagram where like your
foot is on my face right but for me I'm
like whatever right like I think a lot
of personal hygiene things you don't
give a [ __ ] about like you're constantly
like digging your finger in your [ __ ]
nose
um you're like outwardly gross and you
don't care about that I mean clearly
right like I'm not like trying to force
you also like [ __ ] complain about it
all day yeah but uh but honestly like
for me to force you to change do you
feel that
other than the farts I mean I do feel
like you're constantly exercising your
ride as a woman and you're complaining
non-stop just shut the [ __ ] up answer
the [ __ ] question I do feel that
complaining
um like a V8 [ __ ] diesel truck I said
Constance black smoke coming out yes but
does it really matter not really right
okay yeah right yeah yeah so I really
don't care like I'm trying to bicker
about some [ __ ] it's probably I'm like I
don't know so you know I have this
fungal feed infection and you don't even
care I put it on your face
these three toenails that are like
literally like yellow and four times
thicker than the other two toenails and
the itches from time to time and the
Skin's even peeling
that's crazy bounce
um and you don't even care and you'll
suck on them I'm not gonna [ __ ] suck
on him [ __ ] off I'm not sucking on [ __ ]
when you get horny enough I can make you
do anything not that not that no and if
you haven't exercised you're right
you haven't hit that yet so what makes
you so um like overlooky no like Chinese
with their appetite
you're not Chinese people eat [ __ ]
anything you know like I think the
typical like like the typical American
palette right you go to like a Murray
calendars or like a Denny's it's like
everything's nicely shaped did you just
[ __ ] say Marie Calendars and Denny's
that's like the worst That's like
[ __ ] that's American Chinese that's
like standard right and then you see
like okay cool sausage links or chicken
breasts right it's like oh that's
appetizing it doesn't have claws on it
but when you hear Chinese people get
together it's like are we gonna get
chicken feet tonight yeah the black
phone and it's like what the [ __ ] you go
to a Chinese restaurant and with a whole
family it's like a plate of [ __ ]
snails come out you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah and then so I think my
outwardly appearance is kind of like
very disgusting and you're still cool
with that what makes you so cool with
that uh okay all right so you're not
disgusting your outwardly appearance
really isn't that disgusting right like
we know disgusting like there's [ __ ]
not like personally you know but we've
seen it or there's dudes even females
and we know some of these females that
have like [ __ ]
their hygiene just [ __ ] gross like
they're oily hair like they [ __ ] you
could tell they don't brush their teeth
because they got like the [ __ ] build
up on their teeth like that's disgusting
like that is just right I mean I've seen
you like use dry shampoo for like 14
days straight yeah I'm still dry shampoo
are you gonna wash your hair ever [ __ ]
off why are you trying to throw me at
this [ __ ] bus damn maybe I'm the one
that can overcome a lot you know do I
smell is that what you're saying I'm
just saying like I come out the shower
right I come out the shower and I'm like
damn I feel like I'm in like a you know
like a nice little Irish Spring
commercial and I see your ass like
okay
clean I'm like you sure about that it's
just my hair dude and it's so processed
it's just my hair what are you trying to
say are you trying to hint like do I
smell do I smell
oh no
smell can I smell I'm not gonna say but
the the question's for you because
you're the model right so you're the
model that like disgusting guys in like
what is it that like how come you don't
care about disgustingness
um so I don't know if I
either know or care about what I look
like right like I don't think I've ever
one considered myself like model or
whatever right we've been casted for
American Top Model yeah and so like
that's I mean your Model S you're in
that realm you know
yeah but I I don't turn it down so it's
like it's it's people going oh [ __ ] dude
you got a voice you should be in this R
B group and then it's the person that's
going
um I don't really want to but you've got
that caliber you know yeah yeah so they
casted you you got the caliber and then
you're the one that like I don't know if
I want to do that yeah I don't think
it's I don't think it's that important
like I don't
So like
um and it's funny because I I haven't I
mean I've dated attractive guys right
not that you're not one of them but um
and I know you really don't even give a
[ __ ] but um I don't know if I care about
that right like I don't know if I'm
measuring what like I want to assume the
outwardly world thinks about me and then
my own standard of the the of how
beautiful I think I am like I don't
think I consider that when I'm picking
someone to date oh that's interesting
yeah so like
um it could be like a Ryan Gosling or a
[ __ ] Jason Momoa right but let's say
they don't have confidence they can't
speak up they're [ __ ] dumb
um they're very unathletic uncoordinated
people like they have no Talent like you
know what I mean like then that to me is
so unattractive that I'm like uh so all
the things you just named yeah they're
invisible right yeah and you have to get
to know someone yeah to know if they
have or don't have those things yeah
so doesn't that mean
for you you the only way to see if
someone qualifies for what you want you
have to date them and get to know them
yeah
yeah I mean when I whenever I've dated
or gone on dates one I don't I've never
done like blind dates because I can't
get to know that right yeah and then I
don't want to get stuck with the [ __ ]
weirdo or just someone I just don't gel
with yeah so I've never done that
um I've only met people or guys
I've only the only guys I've ever dated
are guys that are doing the same hobbies
that I'm doing or living the same
lifestyle that I'm living and then we're
forced to interact or maybe not force
but we're just put in a position where
it's easy to interact with each other
um that already tells me a lot right
like I have never like really hit it off
with someone like at a club right
because I'm like one I don't go clubbing
and if I do go clubbing it's just not my
type of
um place to meet people like I just like
deep conversations or connections with
people or with guys I should say not
people but guys so um yeah like anyone
I've ever dated it was because it was
either through work whether we work
together or it was like I see them all
the time at my job place
um mainly school like anything anything
like I said hobby lifestyle like if I'm
living that path then it's it needs to
align to where I'm already going what up
guys this episode is brought to you by
manscape if you haven't heard already
it's smooth sex summer when you're
playing in the Summer sun make sure
you're escaped from your pubes to the
bum and ain't that the truth it's
freaking hot as hell out here in Vegas
and when I'm sweating my ass off and all
of my sweat goes down to my cubes like
when they're there it soaks it all up
and then it feels nasty and wet and then
I don't even want to talk about the
smell which is why I shave regularly so
it stays nice and cool down there and
there's not a bunch of hair that
collects all the sweat and creates a wet
spot down there and the manscape
performance package 4.0 has everything
you need to prepare that summer bot
inside this package you'll find a lot
more 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer which I do use because
sometimes I'm getting old and I got the
old Asian man hairs popping out and they
got their crop preserver bald deodorant
pretty much everything that you need to
make sure it's nice and fresh down there
and I love the LA and I love the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer because it
features a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents so like I
could just go ahead and go in the shower
and I can go rather quickly which is why
it's so easy to maintain my hygiene and
not to mention it's also waterproof so
whether you're doing at the beach the
lake or in the shower which is when I do
it it's so easy because you just shave
in the shower and all the hair goes
right down the drain and it's perfect
it's just part of my routine now so easy
to do not to mention it also makes it
look bigger and now that I'm getting
more lean everything just looks way more
streamlined and I look presentable get
20 off your plus free shipping with the
code get close at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code get
close at manscape.com it's smooth sack
summer boys get on board or get left
behind so technically you've never
I guess had anything like um
like kick off in like a pickup
environment
whether the beach the club whatever but
just like you know like some people
they're like oh yeah I met him at the
whatever and it was like it was our
first interaction and one thing led to
another 10 dates in we're like oh cool
this is really cool like for you
like those kind of like more like pickup
environments would just
like you wouldn't even be able to get to
know people the way you would want to
get to know them at that point that
person would need to jump through hoops
to make it happen again
um yeah because for me I was so focused
on my goals that I'm like
I'm not even ready to like get into
something serious like I even though I
was always in a serious relationship
because I'm just so nitpicky about like
who I want to spend my time with
um that I was just so focused on where I
wanted to go what I wanted to do that
like if you are going down that path
cool but if not then I just I'm not even
looking for it like I was never really
boy crazy either I see that was really
tough for me because uh like I think I
was like you in early college and I
think
um you know like
outside like in high school you pretty
much date within like whoever's in your
high school or your city right yeah and
when you get into college especially if
you go like a four-year you're exposed
to the world almost yeah like you got
people from the East Coast here from
North Carolina I went to UCLA exchange
foreign exchange yeah foreign exchange
students like you said it's a giant
campus I think undergrad alone there's
like 40 50 000 people and then you have
uh graduate school there too so you got
people that are getting an MBA you got
people getting a law degree you know MD
doctor whatever all that stuff so the
campus is huge yeah and who knows who
you're gonna meet I mean I've even seen
like Barry Bonds walking around I've
seen David Beckham drive down the street
it's just a big like worldly place right
like how what was it like seeing Barry
Bonds were you like holy [ __ ] that is a
[ __ ] Behemoth of a man well I always
thought baseball players were [ __ ]
right because they're the only people
but Barry Bonds at his Peak when he was
[ __ ] all roids dude yeah but he was
not but I see look and I kind of dude I
know but if you play sports and you wear
pants I have to laugh at you
what other sports wear pants football
player you talk [ __ ] about football
players what do you call those [ __ ]
quarters
they're pants dude they're tights
they're not pants they don't wear a belt
and have a fly and a zipper baseball
players don't wear a belt they have a
belt are you not paying attention to the
trousers no I'm probably looking at
their ass I'm not looking at that isn't
that weird what I'm like if you can wear
pants and still play this sport the
sports [ __ ] come on just admit it
just listen let's just get it off the
table let's just admit what kind of
sport this is fun I don't know there's
two people literally in the world that
wear pants and play sports one golfers
no oh yeah them like come on three of
them then right baseball players oh my
God you're talking to someone golfers
yeah and horse jockeys
those three are like in their own thing
I don't even know why they're on ESPN
like what would they be poker is more
stressful than those three Sports
stop okay so because of that because of
that I was like I never gave baseball
players no respect but
and then I was running at Drake Stadium
which is the student accessible Stadium
at UCLA
doing my Sprints you know trying to get
myself it would have been student
accessible why did you have to throw
that in there because there's like
private ones and you wanted to yeah
because okay because UCL is huge it's
great facilities they got like teams is
this [ __ ] sponsored by UCLA what the
[ __ ] shout outs to my alumni who calls
me literally every year asking for money
how much have you given none
um so they have uh Drake Stadium right
yeah and I'm running and then I run I go
oh [ __ ]
that's Barry Bonds how did you even know
because you
I just recognize people remember yeah
yeah like I just like remember we're at
a collaboration a few years ago and I
was like oh that's the [ __ ] pushed in
guy from Training Day right and then it
was like get your [ __ ] pushed in bruh
like that guy and I was like that's him
I just don't I just recognize people I
just lost my eyes tell me like they just
they just do their job so I saw Barry
bondsman oh [ __ ] Barry Bonds so I
walked up to him Hey sir are you Barry
Bonds he goes yes I am I'm like can I
shake your hand and go sure I shook his
hand and it literally felt like I was
shaking [ __ ] baseball mitt uh it was
like I was shaking like a Tomahawk Steak
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] big and strong how tall
is he
uh I think like six four because you're
like five six right no five five okay so
he's like six
no he's six four yeah and if I had to
guesstimate yeah he's about to
guesstimate
300 pounds probably 300 to be honest and
probably when he's in season he's in
shape probably like a buff 270. like
he's a big mother [ __ ] and I was like
are you like looking up yeah I was like
holy [ __ ] God damn this guy is [ __ ]
huge yeah yeah uh why are we talking
about no idea
but anyways what I was saying is when I
was in college right
um you know like you always hear of
people or even all the movies and
whatever it's like you people you see
people running into each other at the
bar at frat or sorority houses or clubs
or whatever and you see people dating
and then so like
I'm like oh I need to like put myself
out there and talk to people that's
that's how I felt like that's how that's
the only way I was gonna be able to like
date and talk to chicks
because when I live my lifestyle
there's literally no chicks in my
lifestyle and what was your lifestyle so
I was pre-med
and then when you go to the science part
of the campus it's already like man in
there's probably 10 chicks in every
class
right 90 dudes so that's already low and
then
um I've been like a morning worker outer
and when I go train in the morning it's
literally like there's already less
people and there might be one or two
chicks in there
and then
um I'm in the military at the time and
there's no chance it's literally like
zero chicks and if there is one chick
like there's like 70 dudes on the
waiting list trying to talk to her you
know so like
um I was just like oh [ __ ] like I want
to meet someone that we have the same
lifestyle
or like you know and then in her mind I
think like the younger you are the more
tropey your um
what you imagine life to be right so you
think like oh cool if I'm going to be a
cop I'm going to marry the school
teacher right you think like very Trope
like yeah yeah you have to have like a
cheerleaders exactly yeah so I'm like oh
cool if I'm gonna be a doctor I'm gonna
marry another doctor or another nurse or
maybe uh someone that is like I don't
know has a PHD in some sort of science
some sort of other graduate degree
person yeah like you just think like oh
it's very Trope life that's how it works
right yeah
and um
but I was like damn how do how do these
people like even meet or whatever right
so it was really hard for me to meet
people in my lifestyle and I also didn't
feel like I was equipped with the skills
to even talk to chicks
um like cold call style that you see in
the movies because in high school I just
finished gang banging so like I'm like
I'm I'm an expert at talking to dudes
yeah yeah if I need to intimidate a
[ __ ] that's I'm an expert yeah
but like talking to chicks I'm like oh
[ __ ] you're nervous I'll get nervous and
then or even if I go to a party a house
party I see each other oh man she's cute
I'm like I don't even know what I don't
even know how to subscribe something up
do I do the [ __ ] the the movie come
here often or like the movie thing yeah
like yo you go you're they're at the
punch bowl or you're there grabbing two
Coronas like oh you like Corona too huh
yeah that [ __ ] would [ __ ] annoy me
right because you like and I know
because at the clubs I would see dudes
do the exact movie [ __ ] yeah and then I
look at them and I'm like man this movie
[ __ ] don't even work because I would see
some dude literally get rejected yeah
and I'm like well that was the line I
was gonna use so I'll just stay here and
turn red
you know yeah [ __ ] I don't know so like
I was just really lucky that I was a
business major because like that's where
it's popping yeah it is right like the
business and the humanities yeah that's
[ __ ] all sorts of hot people that's
all the finest chicks already I'm saying
as me
um even at UCLA they have a term for
that what is
it so they have like North Campus people
South Campus people
I was South Campus
oh bomber these kind of guys yeah yeah
no I got it pocket protector yeah yeah I
got it damn I don't know
um I just guessed well one I'm a [ __ ]
chick so I don't have to consider any of
that [ __ ] right yeah
um so [ __ ] I I how did you even do it
were you just like [ __ ] I'm just gonna
I don't know how what did you do so like
the way that I am is um
you know how like when you grab a
balloon
like just stuck down there's there air
in the balloon yeah okay and then some
parts will like pop out or something
whatever yeah so like [ __ ] already
love this analogy really why
it's kind of polluted are you sticking
out of your fingers like like where is
your head
so when I get like feel like I'm
pressured and crushed
I rely on whatever like strength pops
out
right so I get my [ __ ] I'm not talking
to these chicks and I want to talk to
some chicks or do something I'm gonna
get married I'm [ __ ] all of a sudden
like my mom start wearing women's
clothes and you start [ __ ] putting on
an accent no no no but my parents I'm
like my parents are gonna expect me to
get like Asian parents expect you to go
to college and get married right away
somehow even though they don't want you
to date in high school right that's the
trip too
so I'm [ __ ] squeeze the balloon and
then like that something popped out and
that little thing was stopping a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's true [ __ ]
it's not being a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm like all right then that means I'm
gonna just jump [ __ ] feet first
straight into dive into the water
without even knowing how deep it is
so I would literally do that like so my
6 a.m 7 A.M gym sessions check on the
treadmill walk up hey how's it going
and then each time I try to prolong the
conversation like literally like yeah oh
like are you how long on the treadmill
for oh she played the long game no no no
no I would just try different things on
different chicks oh and then some tricks
would shut me down and I just my [ __ ]
ears get all hot I just go oh [ __ ] that
was really bad and I would just keep
trying so you would your open your line
open and was like hey how's it going
yeah and I'm like or I would try like to
say something funny if I could but I'm
so [ __ ] nervous I can't even say
anything funny what how are you nervous
give me something that you're like
trying to
like trying everything like put me in
the mindset of someone that's like 22
right yeah so like I'm like all of a
sudden like I'm from my little city to
the world
and then in the world like there's like
chicks that look like straight up models
that I have never seen in my town
right they're just like on a different
level or you see like chicks that you're
like
oh [ __ ] I think like there's this one
chick in one of my uh acting classes she
was extremely pretty and she's on the uh
uh the competitive cheerleading team of
the school
so
you have that too like the celebrity of
the school right and then UCLA is a D1
school so when you have the celebrity of
the school
they're real like Russell Westbrook was
in my class like he's playing basketball
you know so when he's at your school
he's not the school star he's the real
star later on yeah yeah so that chick
that was in my class I don't know she
might have gone on to the Olympics or
some [ __ ] like that so there's that so
like you go oh whoa I've never met this
caliber of person you know hot yeah or
even that someone like like Michael like
it'd be normal to have Michael Phelps
come in with this duffel and just drop
like he's not Michael Phelps and Michael
Phelps caliber come in just drop his
duffel and you're like oh [ __ ] this guy
just finished training and he's gonna
represent our country in the Olympics
all right what's my opener exactly you
know exactly but I think with me hey
come here often so yeah the cheerleader
chick I would talk to her and I'll try
to make her laugh and I'll try to be
kind of like like I think it was easier
for me to make the class laugh then it
kind of breaks everyone's guard with who
I am yeah yeah and then it's easier to
start a conversation yeah how far did
that go not far because I finally had a
boyfriend obviously you you got a word
with her boyfriend we found out she has
a boyfriend oh who's we
I don't know a lot of people I don't
even know I said
there's a whole [ __ ] gaggle of you
guys [ __ ] trying to hit on her all at
once yeah maybe like you're doing it
wrong bro yeah maybe it was my college
my high school and my junior high self
all found out she had a boyfriend [ __ ]
okay you know so it would be so I found
usually do so I found out that was like
one method and that was like more like
um natural to me because like okay cool
people kind of know who Bart is yeah
right versus like uh me just going
straight up talk like I've been to the
school library
and then like I'll see a chick on watch
pretty cute and then obviously I'm not
trying to be the The Thirst monger and
just hit up every chick that I think is
cute yeah so I always try to put like
all just might be like two or three
things I put together like oh she might
be pretty cool so I saw a chick that uh
from her books looked like she was in
law school
so I would just go hey like are you are
you in law pre-law and then to talk
people most people are pretty polite
and then I'm just trying to like
immediately the girls going like oh God
I know I know I'm gonna try to like draw
a connection and I'm like oh it's so
hard for you guys oh I'm like cool I
guess so I'm gonna see over there you
know that was it that's it like that
there's just like and um because also
obviously she's older too I'm undergrad
she's graduate school but I was just
trying to like not even not even uh like
the goal wasn't even to like I want to
connect with her it was more so how can
I exercise this muscle of mine because
I'm being such a little [ __ ] did it get
easier though like the more you
exercised it like the quicker you were
to be like okay she's cute let me just
see what's up
or I never got that you never wow I can
imagine it being really hard yeah I
think I've only hit on one guy really uh
where I that I can remember at least it
was in college and I had seen him
um multiple times in that same spot
because I had my own spot where I'm like
I just want to be alone and he was there
and I'm like man he's actually really
attractive and he's not paying attention
to me I'm very interested oh cute yeah
and I don't know anything about him I
didn't know anything about him it was
just based on looks and I mean you can
kind of start like uh creating some type
of read based on how they dress how like
how like if they carry a backpack or
books or like you know write their story
yeah yeah so like he was always a white
tea like regular Denim and like some
skater shoe type of guy like black hair
um and I'm like man he's like really
cool and he doesn't pay attention to me
like wow and he was really attractive so
I remember one time I like walked up to
him and I sat down next to him and I was
like um hey like I always see you just
like waiting here like all the time like
I'm like what do you what do you do here
and then we just started talking but
it's different right because I'm a girl
when the girl starts the conversation
you're like damn Lottery yeah but for me
I was trying to work him like I was I
was using my game on him because I'm
just like which is stupid because I'm
like I don't even think I need a game
now that I'm older when you're a girl
yeah you can literally just go do you
want my number yeah and boom is done
yeah well I mean I didn't I didn't want
to assume either right like no you don't
I'm just telling you that's how the
world works like just like how
like there's gravity
it's like that you literally go you want
my number
and then that's it's done you're sir
Newton Quan yes
um yeah so like but I'm like I need to
stand out like I need to make my my Mark
here and like I want to already jump
into some deep but it's so stupid but I
was just like so it was something that
um like what did you what did you learn
today
what the [ __ ] the RBF what the [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] attitude why I don't
have an RB what you learn to no I don't
have an RBF when I'm trying to work you
know like I'm definitely much softer the
RBF comes because I don't want people to
[ __ ] why'd you [ __ ] like like
Flinch at him oh I'm sorry I mean it I
don't know what do you say what do you
say to that oh then we just started
talking of course oh of course and then
I found out he was just kind of weird so
I was like okay cool oh the conversation
wasn't flowing uh he was really sweet
really kind and stuff but like he was a
little too soft for me
um what did you want someone to like
[ __ ] bite back a little bit no no not
like rude or like but it was just like
his demeanor was more on like an
emotional like poem type of guy like
listens to why is your eye twitching are
you all right no it just sounds like the
dream Dreamboat not for me I'm a [ __ ]
I'm with your [ __ ] Barbarian ass you
know like I like barbarians I don't know
if you made a mistake with me or not but
I'm just describing
average girl's dream boat like a
handsome
poetry what the [ __ ] I know he probably
carried a guitar in that like those few
days that I saw him he just didn't bring
his guitar and I'm just not a guitar
playing in public type of girl that's
attracted to that like I just don't like
that to me is just not my type of guy
like if you look like you bring a guitar
to [ __ ] school just to casually play
it like the cringe for me like I'm not
attracted to that and once we started
talking I'm like ooh you write poems Han
you probably like
we'll probably cry together a lot I'm
like yeah that's not it but that was
like my only time that I was just like
all right let me shoot my shot real
quick
you're weird
I know I mean though this is why we're
together and I think I think we're
attracted to the guy that's like
carrying a [ __ ] ladder around
you oh every time I go to Home Depot I'm
like [ __ ] yeah
who is he smelly you're at school and
you're not even looking at the suit and
just looking at the repairs people yeah
not maintenance guys
I like a capable man you know damn you
see how many keys are on his waist oh
[ __ ] I know [ __ ] jingle into my heart
baby oh there's a one time uh you
actually met her the girl that I started
from scratch yeah that was able to take
it to almost like a semi relationship
how did you start that
so
you know for me she was hot she was very
attractive thank you for me she's more
attractive than me like by far thank you
thank you for not agreeing so for me you
stay on the bed tonight
you know how like I was trying to
exercise that muscle right yeah so
um I'm always trying to like put myself
out there I was like okay cool like my
typical
schedule
doesn't allow for me to interact with
with them hot [ __ ] with even [ __ ]
chicks in general yeah it's just a
horrible like no one's training at five
or six a.m in the morning yes and then
I'm the weirdo that's like running two
laps around the school because I'm
trying to get promoted in the Marine
Corps no one's doing that [ __ ] ain't
nobody [ __ ] uh going to the library
on Friday night because everyone's going
out partying like my schedule was just
[ __ ] anti-puss and I was like well
what can I do but I still want to like
uh meet people that I feel like I have
common ground rather than just going to
right bar and it's like who knows super
cold who knows where they're from I'm
from like it's just yeah that to me was
like just kind of like throwing darts
blindfolded you know yeah so I was like
you know what I'll just step a little
bit outside of my realm I'll just start
getting involved in school things like
School clubs organizations smart I even
auditioned for school plays just to see
if I can get in and like do just I'm
just throwing myself out there smart and
this was okay wait so this was inspired
uh
oh my God it wasn't even to like expand
your own personal Horizons it was just
because I want to get laid my own
Horizons were too expanded already yeah
my own they're too expanded that is
[ __ ] hilarious because when you're in
pre-med you you're [ __ ] overwhelmed
I'll give it to you man that was really
smart very smart move like I'm already
like trying to volunteer like 50 to 100
hours every quarter yeah I mean you you
had your eye on that I was in the Marine
Corps like come on yeah yeah your
horizons are spread so
um but I was like you know what all I
want I also want to be productive so I'm
gonna do things like I could still put
on my my uh like application or whatever
when I try to go to med school because
on those mines that are going to med
school right so I found a club that was
associated with
um my Majors my major is psychobiology
and then
um I found like a list of clubs and one
of them was kind of like a uh like a
peer counseling like mental health type
of club and I'm like oh that sounds
pretty cool I always like to talk to
people and then I always felt like even
you like to talk to people yeah personal
intimately oh okay yeah that's true yeah
like meeting people at a random bar not
really but like if there was like a
small setting hey this is my buddy Frank
we do whatever I'm like oh should you
race cars that's awesome you know like I
like intimate settings and then
um I was like okay cool that's pretty
cool like I felt like at a young age I
already had quite a few life experience
like not many people that were at UCLA
they probably used to be past gang
bangers yeah so I was like I'd love to
like
involve myself so I remember I went to
the first like club meeting
and then uh I was like oh thank God it's
finally [ __ ] 50 50. like dudes to
chicks
um and I'm like okay cool and then
inside were you scoping and you were
like uh okay cool there's hot [ __ ]
kind of like semi-scoping like scoping
first at the club's cool don't want to
be involved in this but you were scoping
specifically for the the the the caliber
of of the the female well together
okay yeah like I want to make sure the
club's cool
because I don't want to be in a
whack-ass club yeah just for hot chicks
then I'm a [ __ ] thirsty yeah yeah
true okay and then so it's like it's
like both right okay cool and then um so
in my class I was like looking around
and I'm like oh that chick's pretty cute
and then uh although that looks pretty
cute too I'm like cool this class is
cool it's cute enough
and then also uh like there was like two
or three past alumni that came back and
they're just explaining of like how much
this club meant to them oh this is
really cool there's like a lot of
involvement not just in in the school
but also the people from the past and
and they've also gone on to far away bro
stop pitching this [ __ ] okay because
it's like you didn't even give a [ __ ] I
did I did I really did okay and then so
uh cool and then so the first class
first meeting nothing really happened
and then the second meeting
um you know a lot of people always go to
the first meeting to see what it's about
and then literally probably shrink like
60 oh my god oh that's not for me 60
yeah because people's get College
schedules are packed right so if you
have like a Tuesday night whatever
meeting they're bouncing that with is
that worth it you know or do I need to
be in the chess club or I got to be
whatever right so it shrinks a lot it
went from probably like 60 people down
to like 30 people or 40 people like that
and she was still in it I was like oh
this is cool
and then uh then I was slowly like if
there was a time lapse machine you would
probably see me here and then over the
next couple meetings trying to get
closer dang you waited that long well it
just wasn't a time to interact you know
and then what also made me attracted to
her is that she came in Fast and left
fast I'm like oh she's [ __ ] busy
there's some [ __ ] she's trying to do and
so and one of the times since I got
close enough I was able to start
cracking jokes and like you know kind of
do my thing and I think people started
seeing me as like the fun goofy guy and
then so uh
I think one of the times we're supposed
to leave and everyone's leaving
um I was asking where she's going and
then I don't even remember if I was
going in the right direction but I just
said I was going that direction too nice
and so we just started going together
and then
um I I actually forgot if
if I was actually going in that
direction but I made it a thing now that
after every meeting I wish I hope it
that you were it's on the other side I
walk up to wherever
you know oh my God you guys have to go
through [ __ ] moves so much so finally
we're able to go go like that and then
you know then it comes personal talk and
then what I found out like her apartment
it was like two blocks away from my
apartment nice and then uh we ended up
like uh trading numbers and then from
numbers it would talk on the phone here
and there and then so it actually was
like from cold call to interaction to
hanging out yeah and that was I don't
know out of like maybe hundreds of tries
maybe damn and that's right yeah yeah
yeah and I was like this is this is I
was like I don't know how anybody does
this [ __ ] unless you look [ __ ]
handsome as [ __ ] you know yeah yeah if
you look handsome as [ __ ] you don't have
to try at all you have all the [ __ ]
on yourself at the same time James
Franco was going to UCLA and I would be
at James Franco what movie
Oh I thought that was in that movie yet
oh no he's already moving he's he was a
made actor before he went to UCLA oh
[ __ ] yeah what was he what movie at that
time Spider-Man
he could have been Spider-Man Annapolis
uh maybe Pineapple Express
oh wow Pineapple Express made him a
[ __ ] yeah maybe uh yeah he's been in
a ton okay yeah he was pretty much like
he's he was enough where you go that's
James Franco okay right everyone on
campus oh [ __ ] James right go and
there's a Starbucks
um right outside of Campus
and when he's studying it's literally
[ __ ] like 10 chicks surrounding him
you know I'm like damn so when you are
either handsome or you're high caliber
you don't gotta do what I do
that's rough you know yeah no for me um
yeah it was never about a physical thing
like obviously right there has to be
some sort of physical attraction but as
soon as they open their mouth or I see
their capabilities and it's not aligned
to what I'm attracted to which is
um super high confidence very capable
smart depth
um then it the appearance doesn't matter
so if they don't have a lot of those
qualities I'm just like and goal
oriented then I'm like uh it ain't
happening dude yeah yeah you know it's
Kenny just uh like me
like Nostalgia lies and I was like
that's it's actually really ironic that
that chick that I was talking to I used
to text you for advice you remember yeah
because that was her where like because
I think since we've been friends for so
long and we've been on the same page
yeah this was the second
yeah this was like one of the third girl
it was one of the first times where I
was like I don't even remember the
conversation but I was like really
nervous and I was like oh [ __ ] we're
about to hang out for the first time and
we're gonna go to the beach and I was
like I think what I'm gonna do remember
Miguel mix like he was really big right
I was like I think I'm gonna burn a CD
that's like a Miguel mix Cascade mix and
I'll bump it in the car and roll down
the windows and just feel the air of
like yeah I was like that's so tight I
was like what do you think and you're
like oh that she's gonna [ __ ] love it
that's awesome that's the same [ __ ] yeah
The Vibes would be so good [ __ ] yeah and
then I was like all right cool because
PC and my car was sick at the time so
I'm like hell yeah I pictured it Miguel
[ __ ] mixed yeah night time the
[ __ ] moon on the water and then the
[ __ ] nice ass water the beautiful ass
drive cool brisk air I was like oh my
God this is perfect yeah and then uh so
I remember getting in the car about to
drive and once I hit like some like some
like open ways I was like I mean City
check this out and I was like this is
Cascade and Miguel mix and her white ass
was like Cascada I'm like I don't know
who the [ __ ] this God is I'm like no
it's Cascade and then later on I went to
go hear some it's like some [ __ ]
weird like experimental [ __ ] like I was
not experimental but it's definitely not
Cascade it's definitely not worth
listening to yes so so I put uh I only
know that because that's when we were
burning music at that that those years
oh so I would try to get Cascade but
this one's with a c yeah and I was like
no what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like the pop version of
like deep house
it sounded like [ __ ] I don't know
[ __ ] fine weird [ __ ] so I play it
and then the first one I think I believe
the first song on the Miguel makes like
album it's really dope actually I'm
driving I roll down the windows and I
immediately see you go
oh okay I didn't no no it's not cold
right yeah yeah
what did you think I thought that she
got turned on because she got the chills
because it was so [ __ ] sexy yeah I
don't know so she's like it's like cold
and [ __ ] and then her hair is [ __ ]
blown all over the place like all of her
mouth that's like
and I'm like and then I'm like driving
and I'm like what the [ __ ] and I'm like
sounds dope right she's like yeah
yeah can I put the windows up I'm like
[ __ ] and then just the whole time were
you thinking were you like [ __ ]
dumbass Jesus
really really no no no I was just like
damn it this isn't the moment I was like
trying to create yeah you know I was
like God damn it it didn't work it would
have worked on me I know that's cute
that's [ __ ] cute well thanks for
sharing that story dude
um I'm glad we ended up where we ended
up it's super CUNY
um and uh
it was funny I should just [ __ ] fly
them up
he's like this
I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm like how do
they do in the movies because in the
movies when the wind's blowing even if
they're in a convertible it's flowing
perfectly in a direction you know yeah
but then for her I was like
yeah yeah I thought he said she was like
wearing a hoodie and then she ended up
like closing it or some [ __ ] well I
don't remember it could have been maybe
she was cold I think she was also trying
to be polite yeah so I I think she knew
I was trying to set it up so I think she
wasn't trying to be like it's cold can
you like turn down the music and roll
the windows and turn on the heater and
like ruin the vibe you know so I think
she was trying to enjoy herself too
that's funny yeah
um no so like yeah so if they didn't
have like these core qualities that I
was really into which now that I'm
listing this [ __ ] out is [ __ ] really
difficult to find right because I want
sense of humor obviously I want sense of
humor I want major [ __ ] confidence I
want super heavy goal driven I want uh
very grounded in family I want super
righteous thoughts like I'm the [ __ ]
man and this is not women do like I want
a gentleman
um like my standards were [ __ ] high
but what's cool is the stuff that you
care about is also the stuff that
matters yeah you know it's like it has
like a
it's long-term Roi type [ __ ] absolutely
absolutely right versus like oh hot dude
that does whatever it's like how does
that pay off when you're 30 40 50 60
right yeah I don't think I was thinking
long term like that but I just knew the
type of person I was where I'm like I
know I'm quality people like I know I'm
a quality ass chick and I would pride
myself on like not everyone gets the
chance to date me you know so more than
um oh my God I'm so hot like ooh
whatever like I didn't pay attention to
that it was more so like I'm a [ __ ]
strong female
um I'm very independent I handle my [ __ ]
like I take care of myself I mean I'm
repeating myself here but
um and I'm like how am I not going to
get with someone that matches that you
know so everyone else around like the
other the guys that I had immediate
access to I'm just like nah like it's
just not worth my time that was so hard
for me because I felt like I had a lot
of that to offer like I really like you
know
starting in college I've already been
very independent and almost free of
Social and peer pressures right hey
we're gonna go clubbing tonight there's
gonna be hot chicks there what do you
want to do and I'm like no I gotta train
tomorrow at 6 a.m yeah so I'm going to
sleep at 10 yeah right and so that
becomes the butt of the joke from my
college days all the way till now it's
because I'm so goal focused right yeah
and then
um everything it's almost as if I'm
living like a grandpa but very
disciplined Grandpa and doing my thing
and so I'm like I feel like I have a lot
to offer and I I'm not getting [ __ ]
faced every day and I like I care about
like my mental like Fitness Physical
Fitness my career Fitness like like
performance in all aspects of me that I
think make me actually real important
yeah but the problem is I'm like how do
I get
how do you show that yeah how do I show
that yeah you know there's this huge gap
that I'm trying to close yeah because
then if you're also the guy that goes up
to like chicks and you go hey like I'm
very career driven and uh I care I don't
really care about taking care of my body
and I want to take care of my future
wife
they're like get the [ __ ] away you creep
yeah I mean I think uh I think obviously
because you're in your 20s and you're
trying to make something happen right
but a lot of quality females are look I
mean even I I shouldn't even say it's
like a male female thing honestly it's
people will notice right if you're
taking care of your Fitness you can tell
if you're taking care of your career
Fitness you can tell right there's so
many things that words aren't necessary
so let's rewind myself back to
the library right yeah whether it was
that chick that was like uh studying
like law or something yeah
how do I present myself in a way where I
feel like our values match
um I mean that's when the long game has
to now come so that always has to be
long game if you're if you're trying if
you're not already super [ __ ] hot or
like the James Franco already
established I think so yeah because
right like you have to put yourself in
the vicinity I feel like James Franco
[ __ ] walks by her panties are on the
floor of course right because he's
already established it he doesn't need
to say [ __ ] because I walk by and it
goes back up because you already know
what it takes to get to that caliber or
to get to that level in life right like
it took a lot of [ __ ] hard work like
this this like you're walking down the
street and you just get discovered and
now you're a movie star like that's
never been a real thing yeah that's
never been real yeah right even if
you're like a hot ass person or do you
want a model like okay that does happen
and it still happens but it's like for
you to be a [ __ ] well-known model
like a Giselle or like a I don't know
any more model names but
um
um you [ __ ] have to work hard yeah
and I'm not saying the type of work is
you got two characters in the snow
pretend like it's summer right I was
about to say that [ __ ] like you can't
say it's comparable to certain things
but but it's [ __ ] hard though model
is hard to that yeah yeah the modeling
itself is really hard like uh
maintaining your body like as you age
like there's just a lot of things that
go into it right because it's your job
it's a profession and if you care about
it and you have pride in it of course
you want it to be top quality yeah
um so yeah you should be hiring like
nutrition nutritionists coach blah blah
blahs right
um but yeah if you're doing the long
game
either your shorking has to be really
good where it's like very captivating uh
those One ow I'm cramping we just
trained ah oh muscle cramps oh [ __ ] I
don't know where I've never had that
um
ah what was I saying that your long
games versus short game yeah yeah so if
you're short game like if you are like
those pickup line guys where like they
can get to it really really quickly or
add the right amount of pressure to like
make a girl go or whatever
um then solid you're good but if you
don't have the short game strength then
you gotta [ __ ] play the long game
because the right people are paying
attention to what it is that they want
you know like I was my ear was always
open to like conversations or how they
reacted with certain things or how
they're like how the guy's talking about
like a female or how the guy's talking
about a frustration like I was always
always listening to like every
conversation like I would hear something
I didn't like and I'm like okay cool
I'll you're off the roster
and it wasn't even directed to me that
you just see how they behave just out in
the wild you know and I think that's why
when like
um you and I became a thing it was so
easy because I was even observing you
not even like in a romantic way but I
would just see like when all the homies
were like damn look at that chick or
whatever whatever
um you were never that guy and like and
it wasn't like you were trying to
impress me because we didn't even
I mean we were like homies homies homies
you know yeah it was just you being Bart
that I was like oh wow very interesting
but just left it at that so once we
became a thing I already was
so like well
um aware of who you were as just a man
that I'm like sick
sick dude you're sick dude so that's why
you can be as gross as you want because
I'm like okay whatever it's so
superficial like that's not even the
quality that I care for right like in a
perfect world what I want you to not
have fungus feet yeah but is it like
does it make me love you less
even that yeah it's not even like a big
yeah it's so stupid right because it's
youth is is is a fleeting thing like
it's
we're all getting old I actually think
it's a cool story
because I got it in the Marine Corps
from TV boots on all day I mean you
could fix it dude there's [ __ ]
medication I've tried a lot lotions
[ __ ] no like actual prescription like
you see a foot doctor a [ __ ]
podiatrist your cousin's your cousin one
I'm gonna ask him when he graduates
Cindy a pedo yeah I guess he's a pedal
is that what it's called I don't know
they probably don't like that probably
die oh die I don't know pod eyes we're
not petos we're pod eyes yeah yeah so
[ __ ] talk to him and get that [ __ ]
fixed but then I know you're just not
gonna have that story yeah you know yeah
ironically too I really got uh deep into
that club
and I ended up becoming vice president
of that club damn what a stud pretty
cool huh super cool you went in for the
post post and you came out of [ __ ]
you actually I actually really enjoyed
it and that club was pretty cool and
then uh yeah I ended up
becoming vice president of the club I
didn't know that yeah what a stud I'm
dating the vice president it wasn't even
a vice president what they made the
position just for you yeah president so
they were good but just not you had to
be in for a certain amount of time and
then uh so they already nominated a
president like she's like this really
like type A personality like Korean
chick so you already knew like everyone
you should probably be president because
she's like so unlocked and all that
stuff
um and I think senior year she was like
really spread thin and then so she was
like [ __ ] I need someone so they did
like a like a board meeting to open a
second position yeah and then in the
second position uh she nominated me
so I ended up being like the vice
president of it big CUNY guy that's
pretty sick
okay well I'm impressed
um and then on that note that's it baby
we done you scored you had all the right
qualities that I cared about all right
thank you so this [ __ ] oh she's she
Geo's attractive or whatever I'm like
whatever like if I have a shitty
attitude and I'm dumb that [ __ ] doesn't
matter but maybe the guys that maybe the
guys are like
yeah if you're hot then I'll still date
you I do want to give you a compliment
out of all the mouths I've busted and
yours feels the best
[Laughter]
so much for listening we'll catch you
next week bye